look we've seen the mass shootings in
charleston south carolina el paso texas
and pittsburgh
last year in atlanta
this week in dallas texas and now in
buffalo
in buffalo new
york white supremacy is a poison
it's a poison
running through it really is
running through our body politic
and it's been allowed to fester and grow
right in front of our eyes
no more
i mean no more
we need to say as clearly and forced as
we can
that the ideology of white supremacy has
no place in america
none
[Music]
and look
fairly for us to not say that failure is
saying that there's going to be
complicity silence is complicity
it's complicity we cannot remain silent
our nation's strength has always come
from the idea
it's going to sound corny but think
about it what's the idea of our nation
they were all children of god
all life liberty
are universal goods
gifts of god we didn't get it from a
government we got it from because we
exist
were called upon to defend them
the venom of the haters
and their weapons of war
the violence and the words and deeds the
that stalk our streets our stores our
schools
this venom this violence cannot be the
story of our time
we cannot allow that to happen
look i'm not naive
i know tragedy will come again
it cannot be forever overcome
it cannot be fully understood either
but there are certain things we can do
we can keep assault weapons off our
streets
we've done it before
i did it when he passed a crime bill
last time and violence went down
shootings went down
you can't prevent people from being
radicalized to violence
but we can't address the relentless
exploitation of the internet to recruit
and mobilize terrorism
we just need to have the courage to do
that to stand up
look the american experiment
in democracy
is in a danger like it hasn't been in my
lifetime
it's in danger this hour
hate and fear of being given too much
oxygen
by those who pretend to love america
but who don't understand america to
confront the ideology of hate requires
caring about all people
not making distinctions
reverend the scripture
is seen that we're all part of the
divine
love thy neighbor as thyself
that's the america i know that jill
knows
and most deserve the most we just look
we're the most multi-racial most dynamic
nation in the history of the world
now is the time
for the people of all races
from every background
to speak up as a majority in american
and reject white supremacy
these actions
we've seen
in these hate-filled attacks
represent the views of a hate-filled
minority
we can't allow them to distort america
the real america
we can't allow them to destroy the soul
of the nation
as president united states i travel the
world
all the time
and other nations ask me heads of state
in other countries my ask me
what's going on
what in god's name happened on january 6
what happened in buffalo what happened
to ask
we have to refuse to live in a country
where black people going about a weekly
grocery shopping can be gunned down by
weapons of war
deployed
in a racist cause
we have to refuse to live in a country
where fear and lies are packaged for
power
and for profit
we must all enlist
in this great cause of america
this is work that requires all of us
presidents politicians commentators
citizens
none of us can stay in the sidelines